[Music]
it's the screen junkies holiday special
with appearances from Nick Monday Mark
Wahlberg and Will Ferrell Doug Benson
Casper Van Dien Mark Ellis
Jeremy John's black nerd PJ and more and
now your host hound
Rodney what's going on guys it's time
for the screen junkies holiday special
there's going to be mirth merriment and
you know can we uh can we cut cut the
music quite frankly I'm just not feeling
it we already did and anchorman
Christmas special that didn't go well
can we do it a little bit of play-acting
and take us back to the day that Mary
and Joseph tried to get into that in but
we're not gonna mock Christianity right
no okay you sure yes okay yes cuz you
know what what we do I'll kill you I
just don't have any more Christmas
spirit who's at the door
what it's my pal Jeremy John's and Andre
meadow
Oh great to see you holidays thanks we
heard you weren't in the Christmas
spirit this year a little bit down so we
brought you some food from one of your
favorite holiday movies spaghetti
yeah syrup candy Oh
not to be confused with my movie Jewish
elf
let's take a look I'm a Jewish elf from
the Jewish North Pole
aka Florida alright now we're gonna mix
you up something truly special for the
holidays yes true holiday tree let's go
ahead and get that maple some friends
oh there we go so far so good all right
we'll eating this give me the Christmas
spirit it'll give you whatever Beauford
Brimley has I can tell you that yeah
yeah there are some fetish sites that is
very excited Wow I'll come back with a
knife someone shot suicide
I've eaten worse things really well now
I'm curious oh he's going for it pastas
a little bit neutral it's not like
there's like a natural like oh this is
wrong so how do you have the holiday
spirit
no man everyone's being so cool but I
still feel like reindeers who could be
at the door whoa
it's Nick Monte Claus oh ho ho how's it
going I heard you have a little trouble
getting to the old holiday spirit well I
got a surprise for you
oh is that 20 bucks you owe me no it's a
surprise and it's live I sound like the
stars of daddy's home Will Ferrell and
Mark Wahlberg whoa happy holidays screen
junkies how old buddy I just wanted to
thank you again for that Macy Gray DVD I
play it all the time you are very
welcome Will Ferrell thanks for being on
the Christmas special I sure hope it's
better than our last one anyway can I
say something
all right Nick Monday I'm really hurt
okay it's a Monday Monday sir
if Wahlberg says it's Monday it's Monday
I didn't get any Christmas gifts from
you I didn't get any Christmas cards I
sent you all those Omaha Steaks and last
time I spoke with you you know you were
cool with me in the rock but then all of
a sudden you let him officiate the
wedding - no let me officiate
way what's going on look me and him just
have this special bond some kind of [ __ ]
stain
you're right mark a bit of total stain
I'm so sorry to make up for it why'd you
come over to my house well crack oh it's
a brew dad it's ok mark we all need to
scream at NIC Monday sometimes I'm sorry
oh no you you have every right to so you
guys played rival cops and the other
guys and now you're playing rival dads
and daddy's home what's the third movie
in your arrival trilogy got to be
talking about doing playing rival
dancers and remaking what was that a
Baryshnikov gregory hines movie oh yeah
white knights yes yes I know I got once
again guys I cannot thank you enough for
being here are there any holiday wishes
that you want to send out to screen
junkies fans or just everybody out there
in the internet universe hell I think we
lost them to the power of dance
NIC those gentlemen are deep in there
folks don't forget to see daddy's home
opening Christmas Day I want to thank
them again for being here we'll holler
you cheered up you have that Christmas
spirit deep inside you I'm glad you
stopped by and was nice to have them but
no for the sake I mean for the sake of
our bit I'll say no okay yeah shall I
give you a Santa's hug not necessary
okay
Oh your envelope Nick oh gosh please
this is bad touch transition gee whiz
sure it's nice and my friends to stop by
but I still don't think I have the
Christmas spirit what's that sound
it sounds like jingle bells but more
European there Flula bells oh how are
you hey Flula what's going on my friend
I noticed that nobody was a singing for
you chillin Christmas caroling so let's
fix it well that would be fantastic I'd
love to hear a German Christmas caroling
everybody
you made up sugar because you are the
very diabetes today
funny story I have actually eaten a lot
of sugar today ok as you say your
catchphrase bye bye bye bye DJ Flula
well as usual I don't know what just
happened but I do know it was delightful
DJ Flula Christmas man that was pretty
special
but nope still no holiday spirit
who's at the door it's my old pal Marc
Alice hey buddy what's with the cards
it's from my favorite Christmas movie
with which which one is aa Love Actually
not a fan oh that's terrible but how'd
you know I was gonna ask you that yeah
you do
oh yeah what's my favorite Star Wars
ship it is the y-wing so underrated this
whole act is amazing but mark why are
you really here yeah okay Oh mark it
wasn't that great dan what do you do
dan are you still on that trip it was
totally without plot and completely
lacked the magic of the original movie
plus the CGI dinosaurs didn't carry Andy
dude stop being such a stick-in-the-mud
it's fun listen it's the holidays it's
not time for your Jurassic world
argument anymore all right
my holiday Spurs even lower than it was
thanks to you please leave
take your Jurassic world fight to the
parking lot humbug
man that was pretty neat but wouldn't
you know it I still don't have the
Christmas spirit
who could that be Doug Benson from Doug
loves movies hey how you doing thanks
for coming by Doug how'd you get in the
building by the way Security's a little
loose oh I heard that you were not
getting into the Christmas spirit yeah
so I thought I'd bring you a big old
slab of holiday fruitcake just to cheer
you up
wow this looks homemade well I didn't
make it but you okay but still can I
just dive into this thing get on it hmm
is it good yeah what's in it I have no
idea there's no way in hell I would eat
that Oh disgusting somebody gave it to
me out there it's a total stranger I
don't even know what's in it usually
people give me stuff with some pretty
serious weed in it I would slow down if
I were you
really yeah good luck all right bye dad
see you later
[Music]
whoa whoa aren't you handsome actor
Casper Van Dien yes I am
so today you're Casper the ghost yeah
are you a Friendly Ghost is that what
you guys really brought me in here for
stupid Casper jokes wait Casper there's
more of this bit to do thanks so if this
is a holiday special and you're a ghost
you must be here to show me my future
for a guy who hates the holidays you
sure know your tropes are you ready to
see your future I sure AM Casper Van
Dien behold and what exactly did you do
there I'm dramatically showing you your
future okay make sense so should
something be playing because I'm looking
at the wall Shh it's loading oh here it
is oh it's ready press play
who's that that's you 20 years from now
what's going on guys
hit me up on Twitter without the holiday
spirit screen junkies lost its magic and
you lost the show now it's hosted by
Nick Monday no not Nick Monday he'll
alienate our whole audience by save me
from this dark future I can't save you
how only you can save you you know what
to do ah so I'm [ __ ] on the street my
meters about to run out can you uh can
you validate validate for a meter
what are you she's going on give me
money I came here for free
[Music]
by running wait no Casper
you'll be glad to know that I have the
spirit I'm not gonna turn it to Scott
manse and I'm not going to let Nick
Monday take over the screen junkies show
and run it straight into the ground to
become houston astros talk i believe i
believe thank you
casper let's go back to reality whoa
that was so weird
I'm back from the dream and I'm still
the host boy I feel like I found the
Christmas spirit buddy
well I've heard you've had some issues
with your Christmas spirit this season
it's true I got something for you
Santa Claus brought me a present you
guys what is it I brought you a screen
junkies t-shirt Wow thanks Santa
no problem now I can finally wash mine
I think I've learned the true meaning of
Christmas I have the spirit thank you
for watching
Santa thank you for stopping here it's a
busy time of year for you very tough
time of the year for me you know this
has been a great time but there's a ton
of stuff that we couldn't even fit in
here check out our extended screen
junkies Christmas special go to screen
junkies calm and find it on screen
junkies plus or you can check it out on
our app there's so much cool stuff
including honest Christmas trailers
don't miss it I want to thank you for
watching I want to thank Santa Claus hit
me up on Twitter and Merry Christmas
bye-bye there's even more fun you can
see in our extended holiday special
featuring an honest Christmas movie
trailer an exclusive first look at
screen junkies first original series in
terms of field a max landis Christmas
story Christmas movie science and much
more only available at screen junkies
calm
[Music]